in our series a more perfect union we
aim to show that what unites us as
Americans is far greater than what
divides us this morning a moving
expression of gratitude for healthcare
workers at Dulles International Airport
outside Washington United Airlines pilot
Jim Crale fought back his emotions after
learning some volunteers in the battle
against the coronavirus were on his
flight Kris Van Cleave shows us the
inspiring moment I really really
appreciate and thank you for what to do
with his voice cracking and his mind on
his wife Debbie a nurse United Airlines
captain Jim Crale wanted to say thank
you professionals I like coffee with
would you please stand up
I know my wife would be totally
embarrassed a cell phone recorded as he
thanked some of the 15 who had
volunteered to go to New York to help
treat coronavirus patients here are
these people that are willing to risk
everything to go to New York to be able
to help sick people in a time of dire
need thank you to these heroes going to
do this in New York City United and
other carriers are giving free flights
to medical personnel including this
group of 20 volunteer doctors and nurses
from UC San Francisco Medical Center who
went to New York Saturday just the
simple act of saying thank you meant a
lot to people that was that was what it
was for me from that it is how it goes
to every one of those people who have
been willing to run towards the danger
instead of away from it people worthy of
all the thanks you can fit into the
biggest airliner you can find for CBS
this morning Kris Van Cleave Washington
that is so great you know the word hero
gets thrown around a lot but what these
people are doing is truly heroic I've
said it before but I hope when this is
all over we have like a ticker-tape
parade for healthcare workers in this
city Gail oh Anthony I think that is
such a great idea no hero that we know
ever wants to claim the title but they
are certainly that I talked to a doctor
the other day and she said we call this
the 911 of Medicine what they see and
what they do on a daily basis and
continue to go back into the hospital we
are all forever grateful for that